right now investigators trying to figure
out whose remain paddle boaters found at
lake mead police telling us there's no
evidence of foul play here but it begs
the question how many more bodies will
be found now that the lake is at record
low levels and thanks for joining us
here at six o'clock i'm denise valdez
i'm brian loftis the most recent body
was found near colville bay over the
weekend the body in the barrel we've
been telling you about that one that was
found near hemenway harbor as well
christian casares looking into all of
this joining us live in studio with more
that's right guys dropping lake levels
are bringing lots of mysteries to the to
light now despite two bodies being found
people are still flocking to lake mead
to see what they can uncover
this is probably one of the most
positive
buzzes that have been around scuba
diving here locally in a long long time
the recent skeletal remains found at
lake mead is keeping this las vegas
scuba shop busy they say curiosity is
attracting customers looking to explore
the lake there's a big difference
between recreational diving and
underwater criminal investigations where
people who
you don't know what you don't know if
somebody wants to use searches right
knowing how to properly use a compass
but exploring they say can be dangerous
if the person is not equipped correctly
and unfamiliar with the area because
lake mead has so much history underwater
national park service authorities say
safety is key this wind event was was
critical you know i mean like you know
over the weekend you know we had
instances of
you know just visitors you know getting
distressed and lost overturned kayaks
you know so
yeah
the hazards of the lake never go away
the investigation still underway to
identify the two bodies discovered at
hemingway harbor in colville bay metro
police say the most recent discovery
shows no signs of foul play the one
found inside this barrel however does
that victim is believed to have been
shot and murdered in the late 1970s
visibility is probably the biggest
limiting factor but like i said with the
water level dropping the way it is
things are becoming more and more
accessible
well the national park service tells us
that as the busy season is approaching
safety of course is key when you are in
the water now if you do happen to find
something don't remove it don't touch it
instead call 9-1-1 christian casa is
live local now